[Music]
so a uh bartender quits his job after
the boss tells him that he can't get
drunk on his days off wait what on his
days his day's off all right [ __ ] off
that's weird unless he's coming to work
work drunk or missing shifts because
he's still hungover there's got to be a
reason that's the american way dude or
if he goes into that bar five of those
days off it's actually really really
just stupid like this bar this bartender
recently went viral after sharing his
farewell i'm quitting his job type of
message which which is really cool
because i think a lot of people always
want to think about like you know how
badass they can be when they tell their
boss to [ __ ] off the [ __ ] on the boss's
desk is a very popular idea really
taking a big [ __ ] on your boss's desk
yeah didn't bobby lee do that
or maybe it wasn't a boss but it was a
co-worker bobby lee did it i don't think
it's a very popular right bobby lee just
[ __ ] on something like just had to
attach a meaning to it didn't he take a
[ __ ] in the coffee bean mixer and he
mixed it into the coffee bean no wait am
i making this up you might be making
never heard of that sounds so ridiculous
that you can't be making that i think he
just worked at coffee bean because
that's part of their their ingredients
i'm just like it's got that tang too it
really just took a [ __ ] oh yeah it does
taste like [ __ ] oh god i'm mixing it up
i remember him saying like he used to
work at a coffee shop and then in the
coffee bean roaster thing and barber i
don't know i forgot dude no i heard a
coffee bean they're like all right who's
got one on deck let me go you know we
gotta we gotta mix this up for the
morning back
so this uh bartender gets a message
uh from his boss at 2 59 a.m
his bo his boss wrote i need you to come
in 11 a.m to 10 p.m today we have an
event scheduled and one bartender okay
that first man replies politely
reminding his he has a day off tomorrow
so he can't work
his boss quickly turns solo and he's
urged them to be a team player it's not
all about you
man replies why are you now just telling
me at 3 a.m that you need me to work 11
hours tomorrow right
he says i've had a few drinks and i
don't feel like coming into work hung
over and working for that long on my day
off
boss writes back in this text message
that goes viral saying getting too drunk
is not a good look
man replies you're telling the bartender
not to drink on his time off want to
tell the chefs not to eat off the clock
too with a laughing emoji because any
time you add like an emoji it's like
it's so he doesn't want people thinking
that his bartender is an alcoholic you
know okay i i might be outside with you
almost like hey the nazis were right
about some things cry face
and that's like all right that's awesome
it's a little bit cry face like crying
there's a cry like laughing in tears
crying it's like the sideways
see that's different that's different
not the not the death
that [ __ ] with it a little bit the boss
doesn't like it and he warns them that
uh they'll be talking about his attitude
the next time he comes in definitely got
an attitude oh he's got an attitude but
as a manager is that an appropriate way
to talk to your uh employee at 3 a.m not
at 3 a.m i would just not be like oh i
didn't see that i'm asleep you know
maybe they were drunk texting them at 3
a.m to call them to come in for an 11
hour shift at 11 a.m or drunk
i would have somehow tried to i don't
think this guy handled it well i would
have somehow tried to incorporate his
religious views with it as well
but yeah that sounds like you know
something a jew would say
[Laughter]
and then it settles it down a little bit
yeah laughing about that
the employee saying that to the yeah
to the boss employees
no no the boss say that's the employee
i think as a manager because i you know
i have some employees that's the way you
kind of that's the way i would handle
that situation a little bit more i make
it more personalized i think you
definitely want to get it in writing
though right
you definitely want to argue you want to
get in an emoji yeah
it's more personal that way chinese guy
emoji around
[Laughter]
yeah i guess you had some shiraz a
little bit too
he responds to his manager
uh or his boss and he says bartenders
are needed all over the place right now
i think i'll just go work at one of the
dozens of places around here i'll be fed
up with you
and the boss told him that he regret it
and he said and then he responds eat my
ass
no way really
again if there's a way to sign off then
he put in parentheses i said i was drunk
didn't i yeah
that's fantastic that's a pretty spicy
way to talk to employees that is a weird
thing to ask from a bartender to not
drink on his days off it's it's really
more just like the idea that trying to
get him on something yeah he's just
trying to get him there's a shitty ass
manager trying to cover his own ass or
something you know because if he didn't
disclose he was drinking he wouldn't
have been able to say that he wouldn't
the manager would have been able what
was his his concern was i don't want
other people to see that you're drunk
somewhere else like this guy was being
100 and the boss is being like 25. is it
because is it because it's like hey
you're drinking at a competitor's bar no
it's because he said i'm drinking right
now and if i come in at 11. i might be
hungover yeah and he's like being
drunk's not a good look and he's like
you're telling the bartender not to like
drink on their day off he's like you
want me to bartend at 11 a.m i think
that's not a good look bro yeah [ __ ] out
of here like what are you talking about
tell him at 3am i would have just like
seen that and been like i didn't see
that like i'm asleep and that's not
unreasonable to think that i'm asleep
that's crazy that's a crazy thing with
cell phones too now is when i was
working like in high school early
college
you weren't that accessible yeah because
you don't really didn't really have cell
phones so if you got your work schedule
for the next two weeks that's it you're
not gonna have like your boss calling
you or texting you randomly on your
personal phone you know why because this
guy wanted to play hooky and he's like i
need someone to cover that guy's been
over he didn't want to show up and he's
like i'm so [ __ ] up right now yo i
need to get this guy to do this and he's
getting mad at him because he said no
but that's his right as he has a day off
at 2 59 a.m
totally i'm surprised he even texted
back i can't believe he turns it back
yeah i would have been like [ __ ] that
delete didn't see that sorry bro
yeah damn you guys aren't go-getters
dude i'd be like hell yeah and i'll take
over the [ __ ] bar one day
and i'll fire them
that's a go-getter guys that's a
go-getter i do remember one time i was
um nobody hired joe as an employee
you're just trying to er
job that i've had
i always ended up trying to get someone
fired because they pissed me the [ __ ]
off
or they were trying to play hooky on my
shift don't work with joe guys hey good
job there it is like he's like every
place that i work i tried to get the
boss fired yeah yeah
he's like i've been trying it this one
for the last [ __ ] 15 years he's of
the people that's true so if you join
the kindred what do you do what's your
plan of attack against it i don't want
that responsibility man head off the
snake dude yeah yeah he he tries to kill
anthony lee
he got me fast
i thought we were talking about firing
oh yeah that's right it is murder yeah
yeah firing right firing murder i say
fire potato photography come on man
what's the difference dude what do you
want to do
i tie all the laces of the air sessions
together
you're a troll sabotager that's it
they're not going to be like what are
you doing down there get the parents oh
my the disaster of the launch day would
be a disaster bro all these dances
[ __ ] tripping falling immediately do
you think that do you think that they're
so dumb they just put the shoes on
they're just like here we go oh no
the [ __ ] going on this is such white
boy [ __ ] they barely know how to put
shoes on like a white boy show you
that's like a six-year-old sabotage
dream i don't know you double knot it
though
he poops in all the shoes the night
before and you guys put them on
here's a squish and then let me guess
while we trip over cells you throw jacks
on the clock
it marvels why would i do that you guys
are wearing shoes
that'd be the stupidest [ __ ] thing i
could do
i would probably do bouncy balls
to confuse your dancer i got a good idea
since you guys are half masked we would
just be pretend can just and we enter
into other tv shows and just bomb
[ __ ] hard as [ __ ] winner guys
they wouldn't be able to tell nobody
bombs harder than us on tv shows buddy
we'll find out
you think you could dance on all that
stuff yeah america's got talent that's
the tv show do you think you could dance
and they just they just ask people
the [ __ ] other third world country
that jacked the show do you think you
could dance so do you think that you can
dance
so you think you can like dance or
something
so like what you think you're like a
dancer or something
welcome back to so like you think you're
some kind of [ __ ] dancer or something
or like what's up
that was like i was like watching
slumdog millionaire who wants to be a
millionaire right they're doing their
other versions of it and [ __ ] i love
when other countries [ __ ] license are
i love it i love it
oh it's so good